welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happened now is brought to you by
on it for all your supplement needs on
it is definitely the way to go
whether it's room tech sports room check
immune new mood or my favorite how for
brain or the hemp ports protein the
chocolate which they've been out of for
a while but that's as good as it gets in
my world go to Anna calm right now I
can't get your deal on the weights or
the gorillas or all the [ __ ]
kettlebells but as far as the
supplements are concerned I got your 10%
off alright go to on it calm right now
I'm pressing charge
BAM and you got ten percent coming from
uncle joy delivery right the house I
also want to tell you this show
sponsored by CMG links handmade Cuban
chains these guys took care of me two
weeks ago and I lost that [ __ ] card
and I go I know that I forgot something
and I want in my suitcase and there were
these two beautiful silver [ __ ] gold
link chains I put them for bottles so if
you're into that stuff and make Cuban
chains CMG links and Northeast Miami
look them up online they got some great
[ __ ] kick this [ __ ] melee
you
are you kidding me for what Joey Diaz
here your uncle my man hey Zeus trail
what's up man representing the LBC OBC
all day born and raised baby and the
[ __ ] coming out the [ __ ] box
on a Jewish holiday on Friday what's
happening gentlemen chillin man thank
you for having me it's not citing the
years great dude you're a hard worker
man I try man you know here's the deal
bro I've been doing comedy for 26 years
Wow okay and I've been here for 20 of
those years and I've experienced scams
from every Avenue and I never thought
that existed I could look you in the
face and tell you something I stole
things at the Comedy Store but I never
robbed nothing from the county store do
you understand me I might have found the
wallet
yeah well found the Halal bill or family
I found a cellphone accident happened
across that was the time I was so broke
living here I would at night at 2:00 I
would go in the showroom and every night
I was guaranteed to fall and if I was
that broke I would go on the back for
lost and found phones and just clip
three of them when I next thing go to
Christ you know and I had a dude who was
a bank robber who'd buy phones from me
for like 50 bucks a piece a and that's
all I [ __ ] did he used to hang out at
the store at night when Eddie Griffin
and they robbed the bank in that light
two out of the four of them got busted
he was one of them where and I've never
seen him again
Wow [ __ ] tremendous you must have a
lot of cell phones at the house right
now
no he had a cell phone store it was oh
oh I see what he had like live he had
like a real cell phone store but he want
hot cellphones on the side The Sims
right that's great man I'm bored there's
a will there's a way the Hustle is real
out here man the Hustle is real and it's
[ __ ] nuts that I need Oh in comedy
you go on Facebook I'm going on MySpace
and I knew this comic I knew him from
the store when I first started and he
had a misunderstanding with Mitzi she
didn't like his material
she said so she changes the material she
didn't want him back well he went the
hard way he never changed believed in
that material he kept going on myspace I
didn't see him I wasn't at the store I
wouldn't see a man I'd be somewhere else
I didn't see him for about a year and a
half and then when I saw him like that
the improv assignment he went up on
stage and he was doing the same material
meanwhile on MySpace he was right now he
was killing audiences he was on tour and
all this [ __ ] yeah
and you meet this [ __ ] face in this
town you meet these people web dump
comedy for three or four years and they
come out here and then want to latch on
to somebody or they want somebody to
[ __ ] you know spell out for them or
something like that and I see that [ __ ]
it breaks my heart whether it's in
comics fake producers you know like that
everybody stuff about fake news comic
store full of fake producers at night or
it used to be I think they finally got
the hint that nobody's buying your fake
[ __ ] right you know maybe look uh you
know guys in the belly room on Sunday a
buyer - something like that better not
buying that [ __ ] no more right there was
over when the reality show boom came
you'd walk out and there'd be 20 reality
show people talking to you and they were
just they're stealing material hey-zeus
they were just at the store stealing
material sitting in the back waiting for
a comic to say something so I could roll
with the boss same thing with writers
you know same thing with [ __ ] writers
when I first started at the store three
nights a week there'd be a creepy guy
sit in the back he would come out listen
to you after a while what do you do
all right and doorman Greg Shaw stealing
[ __ ] jokes right then one night
you're watching the Dharma and Greg and
they say one of your stupid jokes enjoy
oh please steal my [ __ ] joke yeah
because they would and now it's
different now try this follow comics on
Twitter write copy and paste out that
bit yeah it's [ __ ] crazy because I'm
not a freaking Twitter works I always
when I first got on Twitter I got on
Twitter for the reasons why everybody
else got on Twitter's iconic to exploit
themselves and to see a painted
get to the top with Twitter when I first
got on Twitter I didn't like it but one
day I [ __ ] went to an audition and I
saw Steven Bauer there from dead on the
corner over here and it was a let's take
a picture he took a picture and sent to
me and i retweeted it the guy that wrote
the book saw that picture that I was
auditioning and the next day called my
agent he goes tell Joey whatever role he
wants cuz he watched me on the Rogan
podcast and then the so I call I went
for the small role we asked all that I
am ha ha because I didn't want to seem
greedy there was to my few roles I said
let me I thought if I asked for a little
one yeah he'd go nah you're above that
let's give you the big one but he didn't
say that so I think the other one and I
didn't give a [ __ ] was two or three days
work because you're a kudu that's why
you're like hey there's enough for
everybody listen if you go in then
making demands they're gonna go what the
[ __ ] I put my hand out and you want to
know right you know there's a lot of
directors that'll call you hey Zeus
trail and go hey man hey Zeus where you
doing tomorrow at 8 a.m.
well I'm gonna work out listen I gotta
move down a movie for you be at 8 you
get I'll get Charlie by 8:00 tomorrow
night I'll pay a thousand bucks for the
day these are your friends
when you get the opportunity yeah you
don't get there at 8:00 you get there at
7:00 because he's your friend
yeah you want him to look as good as you
[ __ ] can you don't want him to always
feel confident if he's hires you recall
in 10 minutes late this traffic in Long
Beach and there we got a job again right
7 8 and 7 I don't care if you sit there
all day you'll meet yeah you smoke dope
that's real that's real right living in
Long Beach I gotta wake up so damn early
to make auditions or whatever but it's
like hey it's just the game is i if you
stay here and complain you'll find
something to complain about it it's it's
easy to complain do the work and just
get up early all new people it's so
weird how many people have come here now
I understand people leaving because of
family stuff and there's still comics
they moved in the end but there's still
comics right and he's the top headliner
but he features four guys top notch guys
and they come to town I understand that
and you got a radio job and you're a big
deal I get that [ __ ] all right got it
cuz one day I'm gonna leave here someday
I'm gonna [ __ ] leave you in a small
time I love it
but at the same time those guys that
came here with their nose wide open just
to see what they're getting or giving
and they latch on and then after a few
years they don't get nothing and they
just take off and leave I've seen that a
thousand times now so I know when a guy
calls me and he tells me that I listen
but I also want to see his that movement
yeah I want to see his movement listen
when I first got here from 97 to 2000
500 another minute I don't know what
anybody's told it no I wanted everything
there was no holidays yeah
there was no dates uh hi Joe I'm coming
out to visit for four days I want to see
what's out of here The Comedy Store
eighty-three 31 sunset blow ah
I'll see you there at night I cook yeah
but we want to do it listen there's no
dinners in my [ __ ] life yeah there's
the goddamn comedy at that time I will
go to the comic store at 9:00 because my
spot was that one god forbid there's a
fallout no matter
yes plus you listen to it yeah yeah plus
you listed all the comics mm-hmm
you know I hate it the young comics that
will go up then go [ __ ] out 115 this
sucks well put a sign up and tell people
you don't want your spot I guarantee
you'll get a thousand signatures yeah
within one hour for 115 [ __ ] spy you
have no idea fortunate you are right to
be in that position so that's why always
somebody offers me something sometimes
you get there and you're like sure but
then at the end you have to think about
what's been done nobody moves you your
thing and they're gonna be a [ __ ]
movie star if they like me I thought I'd
be an extra this guy just gave you two
days on the movie you know I gotta have
[ __ ] right when I first got here I did
something oh I did this movie you got
nothing which got nothing
self-fulfilling prophecy on the title
son they got nothing i got nothing but
one of the guys in that movie was one of
the guys that gave Brad Pitt to coffee
in seven he played the cop um Brad Pitt
pulls up with the black dude and he
gives Brad Pitt the car for any thousand
the guy's a fat dude in there or
something when he went to look at the
fat dude girth or whatever that [ __ ]
was what was the guy in the fat dudes
you haven't seen for years oh sorry yeah
so all that dude when he went in and
then on the way out he says something to
him again well that dude got for funding
for a $450 a day shoot like the SAG this
guy came up to me when then he goes hey
man I got this movie I want you to play
a producer it pays for 56 a day it's
three days I don't never tell us
something they're like you shouldn't
take it I'm like are you [ __ ] crazy
yeah this would be my third movie like
somebody just gave me this it's not like
I went in to audition and had a good odd
done negotiate this was given to me you
know yeah and when I got there they had
a couple bigger roles and one of the
guys kept saying bro talk to him that
role is perfect for you why they give it
to him I'm like he said nobody's even
then in 1999 when I was here two years
and who agreed was how people were like
don't go asking for the bigger role yeah
I'm saying like why repeat everybody who
becomes an extra mm-hmm it comes an
extra four three vouchers to become say
write those vouchers you got a better
chance of bumping into a white chick on
the street and [ __ ] her in the ass
three times I'm first meeting then
getting to virtually forecast 22 oh they
hold on to those vouchers like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] would have walked around it and
for people listening you need those to
get your sag don't forget your sad car
but that's a that's a highway to nowhere
that's a highway to nowhere they just
mistreat you they treat you like cattle
they put you in the old area were eating
hamburgers you're getting a cheese
sandwich like you did time that's a call
for nowhere and the big promises if you
get four or three vouchers you become
sag that works in small cities not in
this jungle yeah if you go to Chicago
you'll be sagging in there cuz there's
not a big market for it all right I'll
go PD the other one the other one the
other one yeah you're gonna be on every
[ __ ] shoot yeah it's tough man it's
like you see like in this town I feel
like everyone has a sense of urgency and
it's different the motivation is
different yeah I mean you can see
[ __ ] who just have a weird
motivation like it has to happen now
everybody who comes here it has to
happen now yeah we all owe money we all
know child support we all have debt we
all have everything
I learned the hard way I came here and
made a little money in the beginning not
much but I survived and then I got a
big-time commercial and that really paid
three quarters of it one of my nose and
I smoked half of it so it didn't really
count I paid a couple my bills off but
and I didn't give none of that money up
I was the first time I had money in 15
[ __ ] years Wow
yeah that was the first time I had money
and at commercial yeah baby yeah isn't
it nice when you get those checks in the
mail you're like oh man you start
falling in love with that mailbox like
Jesus cry off you got a little
something-something from when I was a
son Bart Ehrman or at the time mmm there
were my first representation for
commercials they signed me in January of
97 and you in May of 97 I think I booked
something and then I got scratched so I
was on the board with them right away
once you get on the board with an agency
like that at the time they were huge in
fact my agent from there is still in
business at BBA Wow Michael Dell was an
assistant to Neil in this chick she got
out of the business I would go to my
agency smoke a singer or to pick up a
check and leave they were on the ceiling
of a stolen licinia across the mall at
SPP yeah yeah they're over there on the
whoosh right in front of the museum oh
yeah
they were huge they used to have a
Christmas party every year yeah I went
there last year for the first time all
they still have it yeah they cut it out
for a few years
oh wow they cut it out things were rough
and they come out but they used to have
a win when so I think it was Volare
I think he died but Valerie lived on
Gardner up the corner from us okay so
I'd see him at the 7-eleven I became
friends over being slow broke and
calling them up and then going listen
man I got three more payments and a
commercial I can't make it till next
week and I got a grand for me he goes
over 15 no you got it and I went down
they gave me $15 advance yeah he was
always really good to me but like I got
on the board with them fourth of July
weekend I shot the first talk about
commercial with the dog that's great it
was like a million dollars it was my
hunting
whatever's like it was a fortunately I
was a $15 a night comic yeah getting 16
hours a week $75 a week a hundred if I
hosted on Sunday night I was getting 400
a month this in Mikami store will he bar
selling the boys they'd throw me an
extra two you picked up an extra four
gigs about a hundred bucks mm-hmm and
that was it you know and the Laugh
Factory 25 bucks is set and The Improv
15 bucks is set and that was it brother
I would pick up a couple roguish shows
and then he'll you evolve you started
400 a month by when I first started the
first year I was making 200 a month
because I booked their host our emcee
gig mm-hmm that was $50 a week
Wow so right from the book right from
the jump I had money don't have to
analyze a month it's not money but it
covered it's a lot in account of coke
and five cocktails you know the same
finance is the same grreat made you get
into comedy I just had a love for it how
old were you when you first were exposed
to it oh when I was exposed to it so I
don't have a command of the English
language until I was in fifth grade so
where'd you move from I was born and
raised in Long Beach but I grew up with
my dad my dad's a landscaper my mom was
was a nanny they spoke Spanish Spanish
only they're from Mexico yeah I mean and
so I don't have full command of the
language so fifth grade but until then I
was inspired by like chespirito
you know Cantina la la yeah yeah Indian
Maria you know all these I grew up on
caffeine flow come people it was great
and my mom used to whip my ass for
sagging my pants is that why you sagging
your pants
it's like I want to be like on 'theme
flies so it's like my mom thought I
won't be like a rapper was like now I
want to be like I'm T plus cos he would
sag he was a street sweeper Lee he was a
street sweeper that swept by like with
the broom poor Mexican dude and he wore
these like sagging pants a vest yeah it
was great
no I I like I can't even understand what
they're saying but
Paula's mom has Telemundo on all day
every day
yeah caso cerrado I've seen I like that
I like I can understand that show a
little bit but like Mexican comedy is a
very different from America even like
the
the the like the sitcoms have like
bright colors they like it's a 90s does
that like influence you at all since you
would totally I mean that's what I got
an influence to first and then as time
went along I saw like George Lopez and
Paul Rodriguez I'm like oh this is
awesome then time went by and it's like
you know I saw Louie Anderson life with
Louie you know the cartoon and then
Howie Mandel had life with Louie so I
started diving into what stand-ups were
and then with time I just started
picking up CDs and man so by the time I
get out of high school I'm I want to do
it I don't know how to do it you know
and then I went up on my first open mic
when I was in college
when I was 20 years old I bought my ass
off man I bombed so hard drop the mic
what'd you expect ya know yeah it was
all right yeah nobody could judge that
[ __ ] but I bombed so hard that I don't
get up on stage for a full year so at 21
I get back on stage I bomb harder than
the first time if that's even at all
possible I'm talking epic bomb like it
was awful and then I'm like you know
what I probably just stay in college and
do that you know and so I I did that and
then at 23 I I graduated college and I
said you know what
the degrees from our parents this is
your dream you know here you go would
you get a degree in Business
Administration markets assessors good
for you yeah cal state dominguez here
Cal State Dominguez Hills I'm a little
high yeah Cal State Dominguez Hills and
yeah and as soon as as soon as that
happened I started working out the store
and would you pay me stay like he's got
a job Business Administration to grow me
know what are you doing they're still
upset bro my uncle Joey when I tell you
that my dad still brings up the job I
had at Robinson's made that I wore a tie
to work every day is like why are you
parking cars he said you want to be a
clown so you went to college is that
you're doing something that my blood I
never thought I'd see my bloodline never
thought and it's like a now you're
throwing that away to park cars like are
you kidding me
he's like why don't you go back to Robin
says man I was like I was selling kids
clothes dad like the
this I'm going for a bigger dream yeah I
mean which is funny because you know my
dad got like cancer last year and it was
like [ __ ] hit the fan you know I mean
and I took over my dad's business I was
out there like mowing lawns look my
farmer standing out there mowing lawns
like and when my dad came back from
surgery he went to Mexico to get that
surgery when he came back I was mowing
lawns and my dad came out with me and it
was one of those moments where it's like
I all this lost moment I'm like man this
is [ __ ] up like I'm getting a little
traction and stand up but I got to take
a step back
got a mow lawns this sucks you know like
I went to college got educated follow my
dreams now I'm mowing lawns I'm living
the American dream backwards bro and I
told my dad like this couldn't have been
in your dream being a landscaper
couldn't couldn't have been the dream
what was your dream and he told me he
said uh I never had a chance to dream I
had three jobs my whole life so you got
to sleep to have a dream that's why I
sacrificed so you can sleep in and have
a dream and I just said zip kept pushing
a lawnmower man real [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy
what you were with us old-timers and why
they did it why they did it man did you
know it that's what I'm saying everyone
has a different sense of urgency and
motivation I mean mine is my my ill
parents you know it's like when I have
to leave my spot at you know 1:30 in the
morning or whatever it is I leave there
go home get my mom insulin
wake up early give her insulin go mow
lawn or to write a joke or to get ready
to shower up so you're doing real
stand-up right now how long have you
been doing stand-up I just hit my
10-year mark Takai yeah so you doing
with your hand up right now real
stand-up is when you're going through
something yeah I'm working it out with
stand-up and people have no idea that
when you get in your car you start
crying all over again
people have no idea there was a time
when the toughest time in the world for
me was dropping off that poor little
girl in Boulder at 7 o'clock on
Wednesday
mm-hmm so I figured out that the only
way I could do it because I would drop
her off crying in the car for 10 minutes
and then drive home and I can't tell you
what would go through my mother yeah and
then after it by 10 o'clock whether I
had the money or not I'd go get cocaine
and two bottles of fat tire and I just
sit there and wallow in that anger down
that whole thing and then finally I
figured out by the grace of God that
instead of doing that to myself I'm
gonna force myself to do comedy and it
was the worst rule of all time it was
two rooms uh they had on sundays on
wednesdays and follow a line dancing
class
beautiful issues from billy ray cyrus
was huge everybody wanted to do the
achy-breaky heart
Sundays and Wednesdays it was 90 paid
room yeah and then from there you went
to a place called Club 56 where I hit a
kid in the head with a microphone with
all with the ones with the batteries in
them oh nice so the extra-heavy yes
Commerce City Colorado or commerce
Colorado all right then
in there in the middle of Commerce
because this is like a steak house on
the front of Congress but in the middle
of deep in there yeah there was another
place that did comedy then it was just
you know when you go to your dad or your
mom and you tell me you wanna do comedy
and then all your friends and they call
you a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and you're
like I'm telling you man I could do this
I met [ __ ] Joe Rogan the other day and
he told me I could do it in all this
shot [ __ ] you guys and one night you
actually go to this gig yeah and why you
sitting there waiting to go up you
actually think of a suicide that would
be painful like this suicide that you
slit your reacting pills you're not
gonna kind of go to there you're
thinking the suicide but you're thinking
of light yourself on fire it's that type
of [ __ ] you like it the fall experience
oh my god this guy wasn't over some
person
from Vegas and after 20 years he said
[ __ ] it he opened up a little truck
stand in Denver Colorado and he served
pizza and Italian food so he was the
cook the host and then he'd get up on
stage and do a whole Elba's show and I
got tased him he was god-awful
wait I think this his own host he was
everything came into the restaurant he
go hard I'm Elvis I set you down he
won't take your order he'd go in the
back he loved free he was a one-man
operation dirty hands you know [ __ ]
fat old the black wig would slip on see
the white hair ah but he had a heart of
gold the guy had a heart of gold but as
bad as an Elvis impersonator as he was
he put 50 bucks out of his pocket every
Wednesday and Friday for two comedians
and I was always the one guy he called
that's great and 25 bucks but why you
waited to go up yeah at one point you
ever see coaches when they're losing
they drop their heads in their hands
that's what would happen to you you have
a go in your hands right people have no
idea what that feeling is know when you
actually dip your head down and go I
think my friends are right I am a
[ __ ] loser man this isn't gonna work
I'm here in commerce or whatever the
[ __ ] at 11:15 at night following [ __ ]
fat Elvis and there's eight people that
just ate horrible food than a burp and
nobody even got a dessert everybody's
asking for help ourselves because they
got a suggestion from the tomato paste
and now you go up but here's the beauty
in your deepest
deepest darkest moment while you like
sitting there thinking this bad thought
your name gets called yeah and you shake
the guy's hand in front of you and you
squeeze it hard from the anger but you
break this fingers your heart and then
you go onstage and for the first 10
seconds you don't want to be there but
now you're there mm-hmm and you just go
off and they laugh and you're gonna at
that stage
and if somebody came in off and you
heroin and 100 bucks you wouldn't take
it because it would take away the
feeling you're going through right now
Wow yeah that's what people don't get
especially at the early stages when
you're just about to give in to your
[ __ ] friends or your parents or your
girlfriends yeah when you're just about
to give in something like that happens
and you're like I'm good for 30 more
days [ __ ] these [ __ ] yeah I'm
on to something was there one set hey
you guys remember the ones but like that
went that well for you lasers man you
know what yeah yeah I remember I was uh
I was a landscaper with my dad and um it
was just bad like we have to take out
this tree so we changed all the the tree
we have to take it out and I'm out there
taking the roots out of hands and knees
dirty dirty ring around the neck the
whole thing you know and the lady comes
down and she's eating the ice cream and
she's kind of you know telling me hey
you know can you also take this stuff
out and then she's eating the ice cream
she gets a lollipop a stick puts it in
the wrapper and these throws it at me
right he said can you put it with the
other trash and I was like [ __ ]
something yeah yeah yeah no worries so
we do the job and I'm running late
I go home I shower I go to the store I
do my set feel good about it I'm finally
like I'm home this is what I work hard
for all [ __ ] day and then
I'm about to bring on the next comic and
they give me a piece of paper and now
I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm a ladies and
gentlemen next comment needs no
introduction bill burr and people go
nuts and in my head I'm like no one
would [ __ ] believe me what I went
through today the range of [ __ ]
emotions that I had [ __ ] got treated
like a [ __ ] second-class citizen got
to do stand-up follow my dream got some
laughs and got to the break bill hilber
and one [ __ ] night and now I'm
driving home smile here two here so one
minute to another the emotions would
stand up calm yeah man and it's like
every time you and I got to tell you
something out stand-up comedy makes you
believe in religion it does it really
actually believe in religion I was
telling that to Ian Edwards I'm like
when you do stand-up in the
opportunities that come about the people
you meet just a coronary is like you're
insane not to believe in something
whatever it is in something you have to
believe in something to believe that one
person creates all this stuff like
you're creating your own opportunities
no it's it's crazy it's crazy once you
see it happening and then it becomes
like a boom by 1999 how is addicted like
by 1999 I could tell you people honestly
that all I wanted to do is snort coke
until God
I had to look in the I tell you that was
what I live for
after my set there was nothing on the
Dylan cocaine but throughout the day my
dick would get hard thinking about my
12:45 spot follow up all morning
well he would do 45 that's great which
meant I went up at 1:30 hmm you know and
I'd have to hold off I would not do coke
until 1:30 it would be in my pocket
burning a [ __ ] hole at the store I
wouldn't even have a drink I'd be
sitting by the stairs going through
motions and changes and my bones would
hurt but then I would go up there it was
so weird how I got a hook don't stand-up
comedy you know I'm outlining this book
and I was thinking about that chapter
you know getting here and then dealing I
moved here with a bad girlfriend you
know like it was just a bad situation
and even though I was making strides
economy this chick was bringing me down
at a [ __ ] house where you cannot be
brought down your economic your house
has to be clean yeah everything to be
dirty on the outside but your house has
to be clean on the inside you could go
out and go to a Mexican bar and get your
dick sucked with Jorge Perez and do blow
wait come on but when you go home
there's got to be no drama nobody could
say to you where were you
your house has to be clean now this
chick made my house dirty and then when
we broke up I was living on the streets
I was living in Ralphie miss floor or in
my car or my peep you know so it's just
uh but you asked a good question before
you ready for this guy's what's that all
right so I start Tommy and Joe high of
91 part-time cocaine and values I win a
contest I get I can okay hey Zeus I got
about seven minutes
and then I moved to New York and while I
was in New York I worked a little bit
nothing serious nothing to be proud of
but I figured out what needed to be done
sometimes like your dad's job and he
gave me the books you get an idea you
did it with him as a young kid but one
day you figure out how you're gonna do
it what needs to be done for you to do
this business where are five days a week
make a living pay your employees there
and the same thing happens with comedy
one day it hit you like a punch in the
[ __ ] face yeah
and now the next decision is if you want
to take it to that next level right they
put it on you you know when it's time
when you're an open mic ER like I was an
open mic or ready to get 15 minutes paid
but that's it
I paid these dues I've done all these
bars I've rolled back to Denver I got
back to Denver October
of 93 and that was it I got a notebook
and I wrote every set that lit my goal
was 20 spots a month I would do 16 18 19
this was on for about seven months I got
up to about 20 minutes nice
all right Jimmy a beta dear friend of
mine comic in Denver you know if you
ever endeavor look at Jimmy AB and he'll
put you on some [ __ ] show I like that
oh yeah in those days that was Andy
Payton
The Comedy Works and Jimmy Abeyta down
my bread and butter
whenever the page will call from Jimmy
Baker that was a gig somewhere 450 of
burrito there was always something
coming to you from Jimmy a bed
god bless his soul and I [ __ ] went to
one of Jimmy's rooms in Arvada which was
a dump
but 40 people on a Tuesday night I'm
supposed to feed you but the headliner
is show
something has something weird happened
okay so I got onstage
I thought something weird happened I get
on stage and I'm up there doing my thing
my Tony's done bro you don't say I know
that's what he's done
oh man when you get into that last joke
you're like oh yeah you might even
forgot a dough I don't see no light he's
gonna give me light at 15
I could kill 15 yeah 19 tight is 15 [ __ ]
when I do this [ __ ] do this [ __ ] so I go
up there with timing for 15 no I go up
there with timing for 19 and I'm gonna
speed up the last three lights which
were garbage I'm not gonna sit and tell
you there was nothing [ __ ] come ahead
and I get to the three lines and there's
no Jimmy a band and now I do another
whatever i mighta borrowed a few jokes
it was like whatever I don't [ __ ]
know and I just improvise yeah which I
was very good at because when I started
it was the same customers every week
after six weeks I figured out I can't
write five minutes a week I just started
yeah so I started improvising and I was
pretty good at that he's improvising
different from crowd work same time for
anything else Earth Day and it's garbage
you know you get away with it for a year
or two and you get good at it yeah but
then comics will start complaining about
you don't know what up damn people
yelling up at me I'll knock it off cuz
you open the floodgates when you start
opening this if you don't think it's
okay to talk and that's like awful
Russian taboo so well I got before I got
down here somebody pulled me aside to
Seattle said Oh lighten up on the
[ __ ] crowd work
don't even go there no more it was tough
it will get a tough habit to break cuz I
would just go there no material go there
I can be funny for hours and no material
goof on you yeah and when I moved down
here that [ __ ] and
because as soon as people see that the
industry you're done you're done you're
done cuz then it says hey ki he can't
write a joke your hand this can I even
though you probably sitting there words
on some people and I'll tell you what it
works it works here's the difference you
go 5050 when it works it works
mm-hmm but what it does it it's a
nightmare but people pay 25 bucks right
yeah
then in pay 25 bucks to see you [ __ ]
talk that [ __ ] it's great for 20 minutes
you know yeah after 20 minutes you're
like okay I'm sick of [ __ ] already
right because there's really nothing
there and I don't mean to offend anybody
who does that [ __ ] I know a lot of
people will [ __ ] dynamite at it yeah
no dynamite at it you know I don't know
for me it's it's a little bit anxiety
producing as an audience member because
you don't wanna be picked on next right
yeah people always worry about that but
I mean there's a place at least for me
I'll say what I I like to throw in crowd
work when it comes down to like the
check drop spot you know I mean people
aren't paying attention so I can give
them material with your narrative so I
do little crowd work and then close out
with you know material something strong
yeah to wake them up it's funny so I go
up on the stage I'm waiting for this
life yeah and I'm waiting for this life
I'm up there and I gotta be honest she
amazes travel at that time I never
really killed you guess what oh yes I've
killed it and I'm going and I'm going I
don't see no light love panic and deep
down inside all about to piss my pants
and set my pants at the same time but
I'm actually keeping it together and
somewhere in that night I see a light
I'm like okay good I thank you and I get
off this stage Jimmy runs up he get so
he brings somebody up he gets off like
Oh Jimmy what happened he was proud I'm
sorry I went out of the car with some
broad it got ugly he goes but the good
news is bro you just 43 minutes I heard
you killed yeah I go 43 minutes and in
those days there was a newspaper called
Just for Laughs which I'd talked about a
thousand
times on this podcast the last three
pages were all the comedy clubs in law
in the country and I [ __ ] circled all
of that jam call it all money tomorrow
then I open the Judy Carter workbook and
then went through all the agencies that
listed the ones I was on a call the next
day and I actually went because I didn't
have a phone yeah I would have to go to
the gas station here's a phone card
that's great and I went to the gas
station got a phone call that the three
cost like I was called like I see em hi
hi this is Jennifer good morning for
callin I see another Jennifer who's your
top agent that way who's this who's this
this is Joey Diaz I did 43 minutes he
sees calm little dark haze and borrowing
your last night our vana that Ulysses 43
minutes a gold who do you suggest me to
it's that's how bad you get like after
you get that boost you go on that's the
first boost you get before you get down
you walk into a club ticking you're
[ __ ] with Johnnie Rickles and you go
up on stage yeah biggest dick in the
[ __ ] world and you go back to Ground
Zero and now you're back now you
understand how ego does not work in
comedy it doesn't man yeah you got a
dissolve ego as quick as possible
there's all then once you dissolve your
ego and you don't give a [ __ ] if you
bomb and you talk about it freely yeah
and people could goof on your body and
you actually go Jesus thank you yeah I
thought I was the only one that ain't a
bag of dicks that's where it becomes
real it becomes real listen nobody wants
to bomb and for some you throw in your
face no ID you calmly go blah to pull
your side no whew that was a rough show
me I didn't want the money yeah I mean
what the 25 bucks let's get out of here
they might hit this with a glass yeah no
come on let me get the money we need
those bombs suck well you're like I
don't even want the money keep it bro
yeah I'm at it I'll take the money no
you did good don't worry about that dude
that helped the speaker's plugged up
hilarious and you driving back in your
car from this [ __ ] bar gang and you
ego and that's what it always on you
that
maybe your friends are right your family
and actually two days before that you
weren't in the paper look on this a
paint store that meets out that you get
that job and [ __ ]
and one of those bombs makes you think
about that paint store and you actually
wake up the next day drive to the paint
store and then the drive to the paint
store you're paid you also a man where
are you over here why we need you up in
Cheyenne Wyoming tiller by 8 o'clock
y'all even while before traffic halfway
there bro pays $150 and you're making on
in $50 I'll take a helicopter and then
you go like this to the paint store [ __ ]
you and you pull away that's what
happens now catch those type of
religious breaks I was telling somebody
titled potato for four years is a comic
you live this certain life this a four
year span that I live with Lee and Lee's
my brother so he goes listen I'm taking
the big bedroom I pay a thousand bucks
give me 400 a month get some groceries
from time to time and help me redo
utilities and clean the place I'm in
late least my buddy
I can bust Lee's balls all I want above
the first I want to give him this $400
yeah as a comic
I'm the 25th you don't have four dimes
to rub together
you're like you actually have gonna have
to go to [ __ ] Lee who wouldn't care
but I love him and he left me this
bedroom and I gotta give him this four
yards that's all that matters to me is
least four yards I don't even think it
groceries this week real cover me
don't let me give those four yards how
timely get groceries gonna give you 50
bucks next week after this game Lee I
can't tell you how many times I've
gotten a call on the 26th and 9:30 at
night to pay me a $400 gate for four
three shows at some bar and I'm gonna
set that and I've actually cried like as
you hang up the phone you actually cry
yeah because you go you know what Mick
Jagger said it best you don't always get
what you want but you get what you need
yeah as long as I keep putting this
energy out there now something starts to
happen when hey-zeus calls me go Joey
what's up dog Joey you know I'm your dog
I need a big favor headline long between
I can't pay I'll give you five drink
tickets you go down there you do two of
those pages let me do a full moon Joey I
got you next time I'm just short the
[ __ ] do wants to pay me 50 bucks I'll
give you $10 hey Zeus I know what's
going on in your life keep it sometimes
you do two or three of those you know
for people who really sincere don't call
me heads of trail and go Joey come on
down hair can't pay it and I get there
there's 20 at the door
and I see you smiling with a gold chain
on yeah don't do that don't embarrass me
because then I'll be angry with you but
if you say to me long joy I open up a
spawn long beach dog it's a topless pot
they'll feed you they got your picture
on the wall already their fans bro Larry
hooked me up with this it's 7:30 on
whatever I'll give you money for you you
know what bro I know where you're coming
from right but don't call me in and then
I get down and you charges 25 bucks and
you're paying [ __ ] don't make me say
names you know I'm saying like you ever
get to a gig and they're paying
somebody's shitty yeah your shitty but
he's really shitty but he's getting 30
bucks yeah yeah like there's all these
things as a young comic that drive you
crazy in the test your will know
attachme I don't want to do this you
gotta want to do this and I see people
coming out of here
they come on here with this half a heart
they want to play this game but it's
just a game for them they are sniffing
around to see what door opens yeah
they're not putting it the proper work
that's been in their wheels and
eventually you spin your wheel for so
long it's over for you
I've seen it a thousand times
well a thousand times even through all
that cocaine and all that [ __ ]
I wasn't spending my wheels my goal was
to make a move every 90 days what I
consider removing those days it's not
what you should it's not many people you
shoot a - you shoot a Thursday night set
at the spawn and you're back in your
mind you go listen I got a spot Tuesday
when's that but I'm lucky and on
Thursday night set that's my showcase in
my mind that's what Warner Brothers is
there that's from Pink Floyd's in the
room everybody's in psych yourself out
for that one yeah those were my goals if
I killed on the Thursday my weekly goal
got hit and then my other goal was the
book of theatrical job or commercial to
make it a stride every 90 days it was a
strike don't worry about what the
[ __ ] pace stop with the [ __ ]
payment you never saying you want
something even if I come to you go
talking only it's a SAG promo you ever
shoot a SAG promo
no but the there's a public service
announcement they say oh yeah yeah I'll
get to a sag promo you're like oh [ __ ]
I'm like oh [ __ ]
the first sag bro boy shot was with
Sebastian Maniscalco
oh nice so [ __ ] uh politically
incorrect 2004 soprano a week for mafia
week okay when they showcase The
Sopranos and there's some crime bosses
to [ __ ] and me and Sebastian go down in
the back of my mind double they and I
had sudden bought the van Ari no guy
sent me out for that I get down that
book at the next day I go down it Sutton
watches goes go down there and in those
days when they give you the contracts it
tells you your rate right on the
contract between me and your Hayes this
trail ah I sat there in there
I just dreamt of for some reason they
had the number 2100 and my I thought it
was like a buyout yeah I think I'll air
at all week he'd be say during the soap
operas and all that [ __ ] no they're
gonna run this promo during every show
every 20 minutes so tonight on ABC its
mafia week and me and Sebastian would
walk in and karate chop whatever
something there was some stupid sketch
we did they were gonna do that then
we're gonna do that okay so I figured
[ __ ] if it's we shooting Monday if we're
shooting Thursday and they're gonna air
it must start the Sun Sunday they're
gonna air it ten times at night how much
is that if you get a commercial porn
spot yeah at 2,500 bucks
I totally if you get an a spot
commercial yeah yeah that's 2500 and
upfront and it starts at 6 55 54 52 51
50 goes back to 900 and every time they
rear it they were negotiating just it
just goes crazy and you're getting
checks in the mail and your heads about
to explode you ready for the number on
that [ __ ] contract and drumroll
please three hundred and fifty dollars
oh my heart's up I'm like a [ __ ] promo
with whatever from politically incorrect
who's on HBO now man I'm like $350 sag
why do I pay these people why do I pay
these people [ __ ] then a dime 350
that Robin me yeah
if I shot a commercial for politically
incorrect and it ran hey sides and they
pay me legitimately you walk on there
with a total Lou sax playing at 350 per
promo that's why I probably her problems
and nothing close to shoot day Wow no
residual and you got to pay taxes on
that yeah and it had a commission
35 bucks yeah select the end of the day
you get 350 again 292 75 yeah see you
getting 230 buck to be on ABC during
primetime and everyone's gonna call Youm
like I saw you that can I borrow a
hundred
all right I don't have it I don't have
it but you make it stride you went to
Montreal yeah
tomorrow night you're gonna be on
[ __ ] the dude that can have it later
yeah James Corden hopefully you do some
karaoke oh yeah well yeah I'm off for
whatever man I thought I heard through
the grapevine and he's like Harvey
Weinstein's nephew he might touch a
little cooler oh hey rich in the sketch
but I might just have a 350 no longevity
on that take the bullet let's grab your
little Mexican ass who gives a [ __ ] you
know your cousin's did worse Marion
hey sure you can hustling I've been
hustling baby I see it and that's what
I'm saying
tonight when I talk to you when I spoke
to you this morning we were sitting
around and a friend of mine wasn't
calling tonight and I'm sitting in a row
where this [ __ ] Hazel's trail kid I
hear is a name every other week which is
big for a guy like me because I'm not
having no circle
I've been no circle so when I hear name
then I see you you're always a gentleman
you always polite I knew for a while
your family was going through something
they were supposed to do it better for
the son myself involved but I was out of
town so you've always been a gentleman
and you're not walking around with your
nose open I know why that's your Mexican
pride yeah your Mexican pride we're
never allowed you walk around walk a
certain Mexican pride will not allow you
to walk around with your nose open you
rather get thrown over that [ __ ] wall
and so lollipops in the border and bow
down hustle man that's just the way your
people are that tree that you're from my
god Syria you finally came over and got
a [ __ ] loan more and did the best he
could he [ __ ] kept the house alive
with a low blow yeah every time you see
Lomo bow throw a penny added out of
respect for the Jews yeah man I got that
one Jew over to the low boy every time I
see a gardener with his son don't worry
dad did that's what most people's energy
man that's uh most people don't
understand that cry every [ __ ] day
you come here from another country you
get mocked at times while you're out
there with a lawn mower yeah today's
world when all you hear is about all
this [ __ ] you don't hear about the
truth you don't hear about the lady who
puts a stick a little thing and throws
the lollipop action yeah yeah just to
just make you feel worse than what you
already feel like well again your pride
is the one that makes you carry out a
lot more debt you know just - it's so
weird when people do something like that
see a lot Hey people don't look I have
this like I talked to Steve Simone often
and and we have this thing where it's
like look it doesn't come when you call
but is always on time and people
genuinely mean well there's good in
everybody just people sometimes don't
know any better and you can't get mad at
them sometimes their actions are
different than what's really in here or
they're projecting something that look
everybody got [ __ ] on their plate people
carrying a different weighted across we
don't know the weight of it so some
people who you think is an [ __ ]
probably carrying a heavier weight than
the one I'm carrying yeah I mean and I
don't know that it's not for me to know
all I know is that I I'm focused on the
prize yeah I mean that's all of this
it's so weird I'm thinking I'm looking
at you let's see you in that hallway and
then at the store I see you walk by and
you always shake my hand to see how you
are towards people and you know at the
10-year market colony especially those
at the store I was just buying time he's
was I ain't gonna lie I was just behind
time I had no idea that I wasn't being a
podcast for with you yeah
oh and Indianapolis so laughter he shows
yeah that was not even on my agenda I
can't that I was just looking to survive
if I can have an apartment store coke
and do spots at the comedy stuff that's
as good as it was gonna get from it well
somewhere along the line I'd do a line
of coke too much and he was a good
cowboy he was a regular great Buy get
the [ __ ] out of here next when's the
next Ratko cream coming down the pipe
details at 11:00 you know stay tuned
Belushi the other fat dude from [ __ ]
so there live died he's just another
fast car and died from coke that's why I
was happy I got off the coke yeah
because [ __ ] you're gonna die anyway
but I'm gonna have we find me here
yeah my wife's like always say never
came home listen come here and I'm on
the floor I came here into the label
we're all dying we don't want to exit
out yeah we don't expedite a [ __ ] die
from that's too big hell no you said
something interesting earlier hazers you
said both of your parents speaking
Spanish like that's all they speak well
they speak a little bit of English so my
my dad speaks more English because of
work you know or construction that kind
of thing but yeah cause like I I grew up
with my whole life hearing from various
people like oh wow like why don't people
learn English like it's the because I
too busy working people and like yeah
and like some people like even and I get
in some situations but like they would
view it as disrespect just to speak a
different language and to me I never I
never saw it that way but
seeing like in those areas in LA America
where you just don't need English right
right is you don't need you don't need
English because all the signs are in
Spanish in downtown LA so you know
certain parts of you like uh the grocery
stores named el super and super it's not
so it's just uh
what like what are your guys opinions
that you guys obviously speak English
perfectly but do you think of the do you
think it's a respect thing I know your
mom was pretty strict with you Joey but
I don't hate to me I don't see it
go easy um like a disrespect to speak
Spanish uh yeah I mean I mean did you
see it did people I'm not learning
English right did you feel it was
disrespectful I mean your dad was forced
into learning the language because
that's your business
yeah you can't keep walking around
saying Cinco pass off right yeah he
knows work English and those stuff like
that stuff like that I mean obviously if
I was gonna have it like you know I like
to think oh it's English I think what
hay-zu said that he said from a second
language home I don't have command of
the language in fifth grade because I
grew up in an environment that only
spoke Spanish right and once I started
going to school like elementary school
you start interesting getting introduced
to it but I fully got the command of it
coming fifth grade you see I'm saying
he's like they never failed of the
classes before that I was in slow
classes I tested really slow I tested
really bad so I was in slow classes you
know special ed class because it's like
oh you test you test horribly because
you can't speak to win I can't speak the
language or that's not as nice to kids
in my school also yeah these guys are
geniuses but they would go with math
right as something else but two things
they wish they'd fail yeah so they keep
him then I was [ __ ] up well this is
not what you start as well yeah baby
that's right man
shei from [ __ ] cata come up oh it's
Mexican your family first generation my
generation that passed the [ __ ]
eighth grade
nevermind [ __ ] college yeah me so no
no no you have a lot to be proud of
yeah I'm I'm excited it has a lot to be
proud of thank you man that means a lot
man look what I called you today I
didn't know you were gonna be on the
show that means a lot this is all
[ __ ] this is what happens you called
me to extend something and that goodness
you bought out turned around I did not
even know you're gonna be a dad and even
though James called you put comedians on
yeah he's put a handful of people on it
so I'm you know I'm excited to be Cedric
on it and who same boat are gonna be the
guests and your boys on it I'm supposed
to do it last month and I got bumped
Stephen Colbert was coming on which is
fine but look is a blessing in disguise
man cuz you know I've been running this
five minutes set and there was a line on
my opening line in my head it clicked
and it was funny but I just kept running
it on the open mics man I just kept
running it running it just three or four
mics a day just running it and my homie
domani I was hitting uh you know spots
with him and uh he gave me a tag and it
just turned everything around and I'm
like everything happens for a reason
blessing in disguise and I done it then
it would have been fine but now I'm it's
clicking it's clicking bloody hoodie
money honey I'll probably do a set
tonight at the store late night to get
the bomb out the way you know going
they're just you know hungry for love
yeah yeah yeah so I'm excited man I was
able to run the set and you know
everything happens when it's supposed to
you know it's so funny how after a buddy
year you get the system in your head at
the store and you even though you're not
a top-notch comic like you're watching
guys like Bill Byrne and Rogan Rogen you
and without his [ __ ] dice and you're
sitting in the back of the room like
just having all these doubts as a man as
a human being like man I might just got
an ounce of coke instead that I'll never
get hilarious but watching that
everything
being around that Mitzi shore said that
places accomplished it is it's a
four-year college the first year it's
like your first Jinju Jitsu
you're getting beat up no matter where
they put ya no matter what part of the
schedule they're puttin you you're
getting beat up every once the wine gets
some brilliant Sally yeah yeah you know
that open mic I watched you [ __ ] kill
the room but it's a man you know this
does a year year and a half in the store
or you [ __ ] every time you go down
there you might be stepping on a grenade
oh yeah you never know when it's gonna
be fresh Canaan to house fresh per day
you might kill the original root two
times in a row I mean that's am i
standing ovations and words at Carlos
Mencia
I got a semi standing ovation and then
going there [ __ ] you go off your best
that ever in the original room yeah walk
into the main room the exact same set
and not get one nothing not one laugh
leave we'd even with that ride home
feels like you start testing science
comedy what did I do wrong you listen to
the set right and that's why Mitchie
said it was a comedy College you get the
warts ten comments and I see how they
grow they ask what teaching you how
you're supposed to grow now he was
brilliant when it came to that stuff
yeah and it's like the little details of
the place like I remember city seating
people in the original room I was I will
work the doors see people and this is
like 2011 end up - yeah towards the end
of 2011 will your doorman before you
became a regular over two years like two
years and a half I got past September 7
2012 and and I remember the priority I
had seating the room was when they
brought up Argus that I needed to
remember his intro it was like because
when I get past I'm gonna do the first
spot that's part of being past you got a
ring of Argus and has a you know his
intro this next comic you seen him on
tonight's show more times and in comic
he writes for all over 150 newspapers
and magazines
give it up for Argus Hamilton and I and
I remember when I got passed I ran
like an inch or more than my set bro I'm
like I don't want to disrespect our guys
I mean he's the OG there yeah I mean I
can't disrespect him no way I could bomb
but I ain't disrespecting my man you
know and uh I ran the set it was a it
was okay set you know nothing special
gave him the intro when I got off on my
[ __ ] I said the intro and that meant the
world to me keep getting past it was
like hanging out at that pizza joint in
high school where you went and hooked up
with that chick when you were 16 and
when I say a pizza joint this is what's
the word I'm looking for we fishing on
the fictional location like we had what
you had a pizza joint where you went in
high school yeah we could have a
sandwich pasaba
it becomes yeah when you first get to a
store people it's the way this
description you're uh you're a fish out
of water
mmm you just moved here from some
[ __ ] town where you were the King of
Swing and you know some of the guys if
you're that heavy you met three or four
the guys because we came through when
you opened for us we dug you this every
time when I look us up we're at the
store or something but still you come
out here and you're a fish out of water
and he gave that first apartment boy
yeah and you're sweating bullets on how
you gotta pay rent and you get yourself
a gig and I never wanted to work for
Mitzi shore mmm I was the first time I
walked in then I heard the whole thing
you know what I'd love to be a doorman
here but not really I already went
through this in Denver where they see
you not as who you are but what they saw
you with the first tonight so when you
call back four years you're home there's
a thousand comics gonna tell you man my
home club don't book me yeah it's a mom
and tell her you're all here either baby
in there it's a [ __ ] name in so when I
was in there she gave me ba ba ba ba ba
I was very fortunate but Josh wolf then
we laughed about the styles of times he
went in there three or two times and
kill before she made him regulation
three minutes he did like a ten-minute
that she told me company she told to
come back with none
but he came back a little salt some
birds and she does he did great
he want to be a doorman and he cracked
poor Josh wolf you could hear the bones
of the spine going through the puppet
and Justin [ __ ] that I'm not gonna be
a dominant you know because then show
them a pad while I'm there
it was my first couple years there I
couldn't wait to get back mmm like when
I went on the road if I went from the
airport to the store mmm like I would go
to the store Monday night with luggage
yes that's my favorite when the ground
will blow my luggage I took it right
there it should with the money I had in
my pocket and started [ __ ] drinking
at the bar snorting blow on a Monday
night you know it was just sensation
there was just a a weird thing and
different girls were coming there and it
was dark at that time it was dark there
were a couple comics that were young
they were really freaking that yeah you
could tell them up to something I didn't
know what till about like a year later I
said where's that dude it was like you
didn't hear you'll be in the back down
the door goddess that's when you come in
and the door guys would be the door guys
don't get there at 7:00 it's not
drinking in those days it was the way
this thing because of those days it was
a ship that just ran itself yeah there
was no manager there wasn't Authority
and tell you what to do yeah they were
told hands off let's his short talk and
hands off meanwhile she's losing
thousands at the bar yeah because guys
like Mia get in the package and doing
double jacks or double [ __ ] southern
comforts every three minutes that
smoking two cigarettes in oh yeah she
had no idea so she broke even in there
yeah but no we told him all the time
he's the other connoisseur like I
couldn't wait to get back there we I did
not go home and know that a Monday night
and in those days I would fly back on
Monday that's perfect perfectly
like I would party sadly late and sleep
till 11:00 check out at 12:00 and fly
out or whatever hotel I was that that
three o'clock flight which got me to LAX
at 9:30 it always be delayed till 10:30
perfect and then I take a cab to the
comedy store for a small yardstick plus
the tip and I go right inside of them
under night there'd be maybe 60 people
the original room I'd get up real quick
through ten minutes
and then go right back to the bar and
give the bartender 20 and go to work get
five packages for a hundred from the
doorman and we go to work in there and
pray that effective more coming to your
lair because the main room was empty you
could take him into the main room
woman's bathroom and those dish hey that
was the cave of death if a girl agreed
to go ahead to Atlantic oh you had it
she didn't give a [ __ ] about her state
of what nothing nothing Wow
where's Tony Bennett [ __ ]
you
let me give some shoutouts real quick
Amanda W dr. Diana cold Tucker thank you
for coming for the Kentucky shows you
people good [ __ ] people had a good
time in Kentucky
Josh County Nick Alvarado and drew none
DL my little [ __ ] buddy up in Nyack
New York swinging dick Bubba Hodge boys
my [ __ ] savages smoking reefer in the
morning with me up periscope
sir alex ferguson and river c-137 I love
you [ __ ] and I'll tell you guys
myself real quick tremendous
like you said hazel you don't know where
your days are in lot more you did there
was given on two percent I got up this
morning at a conference call I had a
sense some guys some [ __ ] emails I
went to jujitsu and I had a meeting with
these [ __ ] dudes and then from there
I went home I mean I went over about
4:30 4:30 5:00 I have to pick the baby
up at 5:30 so I usually work on the
computer till 5:00 and then at 5:00 I
watch the news with ice on my knees as I
get booked for 20-25 minutes and then I
go pick up the baby so I get home and I
get on Facebook and get on a bunch of
[ __ ] I'm going through stop sending
emails and something when I went there
Facebook I like click I clicked on
messages but it hit the yellow one by
mistake and I said you have four
messages and I clicked on that link and
I went to it and I saw this [ __ ] name
and it said something I don't know what
caught me to open there was a bunch of
[ __ ] things it was like messenger
which you don't tap into for some reason
it just lurks on your Facebook so it
said I have like I don't know how many
messes I tap into it and I see this
[ __ ] Trevor you know
as Trevor wheeler and it ranks up in my
head I like clicked on the link let's
grow and it's a picture of me as a young
savage why playing with this kid doing
karate okay wow he's got to be two maybe
three and the story goes my first first
first got into Karpis it's the first
[ __ ] day I meet this slick cool
[ __ ] that only a person like
myself can make God put these people in
my life for some reason my next book
after this was well the angels in my
life I got about 15 that I don't like I
said I have not heard from this guy but
mine that his relationship started six
months before I committed to chronic six
months April of 87 will have met Jim
Whelan
and a Subaru dealer called Bill Kratz
that was known for being thieves and he
was the underboss of the den of thieves
he was that it was a den of thieves done
there was 11 car salesmen and we will
[ __ ] selling tons of cars on that
Court one guy into the being a bank
robber that would rob rob bank so much
time from the car dealership so he could
go for lunch and rob a bank and then
come back another said one guy normal
let he went to prison for something else
we had him with ankle bracelets his [ __ ]
Tim one guy Brian and then becoming a
service guy the one guy Wayne was
another big part of my life but he came
late ahead bill cried his son weren't
there that he was a young kid oh quit
high school you had all these killers
car salesmen and how I got to the car
business was that that store and I hear
the guy's name was Peter Pinto hi I mean
he was kind of giving me the ropes but
the guy who came out to me the first
time and asked me if I wanted a smoker
number or [ __ ] let me teach how to do
something with his Jim Whelan dirt and I
fell in love with him instantly I was a
kid bro I was maybe 25 years old
he may be 37 good-looking dudes short
but then we started doing karate in the
back he was a big Bruce Lee [ __ ] dude
she was a big Bruce Lee dude
he had a book signed by Bruce Lee oh wow
kundo so me and him became Tyler and
Tyler and Tyler right so I'm good at
this car dealership
I'm a young pimp I'm snorting coke I got
a girlfriend howler from making eight
hundred a month to making seven thousand
a month selling cars learning a suit
going to [ __ ] uh not koco's but the
other one the Red Robin I go to Red
Robin to drink the [ __ ] 450
margaritas out of self
I was Johnny Goomba hell yeah I never
cooked again cook it cook it for [ __ ]
maggots I was drawn I was burning
through that money they would give me
like the 2000 dollar advance on the
fifth to pay my bills and then they
would wash me out on the 20th so I would
pick up like two g's on the [ __ ] safe
and then you'd pick up like another
$3,000 xx which dog was the [ __ ] a
lot for a kid like me at that age are
you [ __ ] kidding me three thousand I
was getting a trike first everyday taka
talk about no the other one
del Taco no burrito supreme no that's
Taco Bell what's the hell with
jack-in-the-box jacket about there was a
jack-in-the-box out the corner from the
car dealership langston going there
every day like Johnny Bananas and I get
the fish and shrimp salad that's how I
first learned that that was [ __ ]
communist fresh oh well I would go home
at night [ __ ] my god salad and the
[ __ ] thing was garbage and then I
will eat that and two of those greasy
dollar tuck in those days they gave you
two huge jack-in-the-box will give you
two killer tacos
neither always fat looking all they were
delicious that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
baboon beat what's in your stomach for a
week and a half I have these fries told
me you have to pull over and leave
dodge doors open open the trunk it was
like you ran over somebody that's how
bad your [ __ ] ass would smell ah I
must have gained 30 pounds by so I'm
rocking and rolling up sport below I got
this girlfriend who ended up becoming my
wife
and one day Jim will is they used car
manager and I said Jim you know what man
they're taking away my [ __ ] demo this
is [ __ ] cuz I got a coffee Jim was a
brilliant sound he really was bro he
taught me a lot in the beginning he was
solid so [ __ ] I bought a car from
below the arc be insane just put on the
I'm taking out my check well right how
much for the car 450 all right no
worries
come check there they took $1,000 out
for the car how did it go from a for
$15,000 don't like wow they talked on
250 to dnh and I'll hunt you for the car
wash and I'm like alright but it's still
1500 whatever and I got into an argument
now that the general manager owner of
that place on paper if you looked at he
was just a little tour but between you
and I and later on I came to find out he
was a gangsta he was a gangsta
so he was the back of the satellite a
lot is packed this is what Joey Diaz was
in 1937 before I kidnapped it
Carlos Bob birdies there this guy old
his dad was a big bar what he calls dude
surfer that would come here and then
went there and then there in the summer
and sell cars these were all big guys I
wanted to Peter Pinto and I yelled at
him with her phone why did you take this
money I trusted [ __ ] Jim well it was my
Goomba Jim wheeler was not gonna [ __ ] me
over
so while this is going on a Jim wheelers
in there counting trying to figure out
why they took so much money out for this
cop so this is how high that I was I
went up in a Pinto he said he wouldn't
give me back the money to Monday or
Tuesday and then we became language Oh
relax I have the money free on Monday or
Tuesday I want the [ __ ] check today
so I'm Joey they can't give me the
[ __ ] check that I don't give a [ __ ]
go get the Ellen and Tom I want my
[ __ ] money and then Peter picked on
us if we give you your money you can't
work in no more I looked on and I went
into a service department that was a
[ __ ] sledgehammer one of those light
ones til I jumped on one of the Subaru
gl tens and I said listen if I don't get
my [ __ ] money I'm gonna start
smashing windshields ten minutes later
they came out with the cash Peter Pinto
gave me three others pocket they sent me
home for the day I think about what I
had done
oh yeah I'll never forget it was Jim
wheeler who [ __ ] took me down from
the ledge I had a little quittin I was
still friends of wheeler
I went back and that's where I got
arrested for the kidnapping
ok-hee deterred the cops from what I
heard him and a guy I had a beef with
deterred the cops they sent blaze and
Brent Hazen to my house to wake me up to
let me know the cops were in route that
they could only stall him for so long he
kept telling the cops listen gonna be
here 15 minutes way from and the cops
won't know we want his address to send a
car to his house and they kept making up
lies nah it's the wrong I just forgot
they gave him like a wrong address and
they figured out from my license and
then they shot the [ __ ] over but those
guys cover from me all right bruh here's
where it gets deep I turned myself in my
name comes on the paper
my name was on the paper a couple
[ __ ] times the job I had they sent me
a note don't come back with a check for
250 no listen-only it was step into the
building you know I heard they cut the
article out and put it on the wall to
really disgrace me and [ __ ] like I had a
couple sales with other months and they
took the article put it next to the
salesman like really to break my balls
because the the Chrysler guy and me were
tight I was buying a ton of coke from
the manager at the Chrysler side he was
another one of my angels I love that
dude already Artie is a a big li take a
look at me if we was six four five and
two hundred pounds Jewish Hardy Pressler
taught me to gift the salesmanship like
I thought I was a Salesman Subaru hey I
wasn't [ __ ] talking about the hardy
press then he broke it down from me like
a sponger well step by step if you do
this thing like this you will sell this
car nice
once you step away from this you will
fail and no matter how much it hurts for
me to do what he'd say I did it
and my car numbers doubled because him
from his words he would not get into
[ __ ] into a weird percentage ville
that wouldn't make the [ __ ] customer
until today I use a lot of his methods
yeah till today to negotiate stuff and
absolutely absolutely
so was weird so now I get locked up for
a month everybody knows cops told my car
they go through my house there's more
nickels in the paint but now they're
putting articles in the paint but I
connected me to uh a kid kidnapping
murder they connected me the two things
who do who jumped off his balcony when
the cops had chased them and they
weren't really cops they he jumped off
the back and the people robbed them and
he broke bread he broke both his legs
some [ __ ] and there was a Cuban kid who
was selling coke but he was too getting
like $80,000 from the government to go
to school there because there was no
human kids he was milking them for bells
and Pels cousins and more pals in those
days in the late eighties if he was
Spanish and a white campus you live like
a doctor ah you didn't have to play
football like that they put you in a
category with American Indians they give
those people casinos at those colleges
think I'm like a little dog let's not
tell nobody don't tell of these paleface
[ __ ] is for you people cover
the spread but sorry about what happened
but a couple of Mexicans in here getting
a couple feathers nobody on them nothing
right
don't Tom your name is hey sirs economy
name is Don Aruba from the [ __ ] Zelda
tribe these is Cherokees from [ __ ]
whatever they don't give a [ __ ] just
give him a cocktail they'll be happy to
tell him whatever the [ __ ] you want
he'll give a kamikaze so I do four weeks
in County Jail embarrassment people
already telling my room and at the time
it was tight with me he grew up with me
in Jersey George and he was telling me
listen I was working in there the guy
pulled over and said Moses number my
coke dealers had told me to stop
we dues and don't come off he's hotter
than [ __ ] if he gets out I bet he's
gonna have cops watch them so I was
getting message like hey I ain't you
kidding me hey Zeus why don't you want
to talk to me that what do I can't talk
to you by and people just hang up on me
because by me getting out of jail he
that was a rat
right yeah excellent you know yeah so
now I had a [ __ ] terrible ex on me I
apply that to places for jobs they
thought about it for a day camera
literally I even thought that I even
went the places that would hide being a
[ __ ] the heartbeat and the other time
and they told me though and one day my
phone rang and it was Jim wheel and he
goes hey man I love crowd so I'm looking
for some good salesmen at UH at valley
Longmont Subaru and oh my god so it's
1987 it gives me this job I'm so cracked
on the kidnapping I can't sleep at night
all I'm picking up honest than nine
years they're gonna get me they wanted
me to plea bargain tonight year's
second-degree kidnapping I'm like [ __ ]
90s
I couldn't sell a car I couldn't focus
no he got the company the company wanted
me gone once they found out it was in
the papers the company went them I said
if he's not selling cars is Calico so we
gave me a deal of the server basically
you know gave it to me
we bought a car for like 168 a beautiful
Subaru hatchback two-door which she got
triple for when we got divorced she got
triple for that [ __ ] car tank the car
was mint little red [ __ ] hatchback
Jesus Christ have time for us so now I'm
tight with will I'm tight with wheel and
we were [ __ ] bail me out when nobody
would hire me and talk to me we would
bail me and I got married that December
he invited me to his wedding he had a
little child when the car business when
I say to you hazel what's the offer 250
a month get let's bump bump bump him up
to 280 a bump means that you know your
income goes up when the one kid was born
Trevor he would always refer to him as
the bump my life got bumped now I got to
pay more [ __ ] money to the wife so I
got to stay here all [ __ ] man he was
a great salesman Brown we used to smoke
weed together we used to play the guitar
together and sing he played the guitar
I'd sing we used to do karate
demonstrations in the [ __ ] Club 30 25
26 now I go to prison I go back to
[ __ ] New York I'm doing comedy I come
back who's the first guy called Jim
wheeler wheeler Jim wheeler calls me
back knows what's up my brother I go I'm
looking for a gig come on out it's a
long man I got you a gig at Winkler
Winkler used cars when clear the old man
people making $10,000 they're retards
retouch Wow selling used cars pay here
buying and Mexican people
so they you think I'm kidding you know
you want to call you have no credit
right you're no [ __ ] credit right you
play that angle I'm this car this car is
worth a thousand dollars I'm gonna
charge you 2500 plus the Vig you're
gonna come here every Friday at five
o'clock and give me $160 don't you have
your car you know a family a Spanish
family will pay 160 a week to drive a
decent car back and forth to work and
depend on the family isn't a Maserati
not really it's just a [ __ ] car
you ever seen yeah chopped off though
yeah no his cousin what's his cousin's
name [ __ ] the the Frederico Sanchez
pushing Pablo Escobar well Pablo and the
after they figured out I know any their
cousin yeah well that'll cook together
they're cousins they're all [ __ ]
cousins after they figured that he had
high level cause he put his people in
these [ __ ] weird parts these pieces
of [ __ ] dodge darts
that's what you get when you're a
Spanish family right and you moved too
long ma but you make him back on these
people and he would pay advance so if
the car was if he owned the car for a
thousand bucks and you sold it for 2,500
he would give you like 60% a bonus it
was amazing my first week then make
three grand Wow I started December 18th
that date always [ __ ] with me the
summer I attend yeah I start December
18th I get the first check from him and
then we're going into the second week
and what do you know it's a Christmas
party I go into the Christmas party that
day the lots open but they barbecue and
they're serving food they're doing all
this [ __ ] and I'm playing basket I'm
looking at the people playing back that
and at that time I was doing good shape
my shoulders are good and I can play
basketball that's where I grew up on
doing and I'm looking like this guy like
that's [ __ ] Doug from Aspen babbit a
this way yeah I think some shotgun duck
from a spit shine under so what I bet
him he was Doug okay when I first went
Boulder Colorado sir I bowled the 10th
Aspen Colorado from February of 80 of 83
to February of 84 there was a kid who
was it you know one of us young you know
chick guy good-looking guy and then they
was Doug he sold powder
he sold pills he worked at the hotel
where we all hung out you know hell no
not his clique but in his clique there
was two cliques that the Crestwood hotel
in those days and Wow hung out with
Vince and his brother
car hall and there was somebody else who
lived in the Vicky's and then they had
their clique Brian
shotgun Doug Brian was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
who later on I tolerated but everyone
saw why you wanted to smack him in the
mouth for a stupid statement he was he
was too old
how does he go from just Doug - shotgun
Doug okay very interesting question how
did you get bumped
I didn't get bumped into shotgun okay so
I leave til 84 this all goes down what
I'm telling you right now is going down
in 91
no this is going down in 93 this is how
long I know Jim wheeler so I met wheel
in 87 and he always had my [ __ ]
back and then I do by the name away
means went to Bill crotch Subaru and I
went back to work for them and way means
was my mentor as a matter of fact let's
be honest with each other
you don't used to tell me the church
what's happening now Wayne means
because when means had a belief Wayne
means you say me listen daughter I don't
give a [ __ ] what you did yesterday you
were [ __ ] what you did the day before up
from the church or what's happenin Ellen
up from Missouri you got to show me
[ __ ] tell half of the
show-me-state he was a white dude
that was gorgeous with short hair and a
beard before beard was cool he would
have a long beard Chuck Norris like yeah
very tight but in the summer in the
winter he would disappear mmm he would
be well he was a biker with the Mongols
or something like that and he would
disappear and he laid his beard back and
then you see him a week before April and
then he was with his beard with the long
hair he'd give you a hug with this
lather on and the whole thing and then a
week later you saw him with a 6-iron
officer with hair looking like Pat Riley
and the beard cut short with blue eyes
and he was another great man that taught
me another angle of sales but how to be
a man look at you got shining his shoes
I even [ __ ] sell a car with shitty
shoes he always he would [ __ ] suspend
people if you had shitty shoes it drove
him crazy if you reassure wasn't ironed
it drove him crazy if you wore a [ __ ]
up tie with with with a shirt with
designs okay taught me a lot but anyway
like the shotgun duck so now I come back
in it's a snow bass in 85 I don't
[ __ ] know 86 and one day I see duck
and I go Doug what's going on if
somebody whispers I'm gonna he's not
Doug is more he's shotgun Dutch
something like Doug what's going on here
nothing good to see I'm selling some
blow I think I buy some blow food so I
go through my but now with Doug's leg
was a regular guy you know he did drugs
but I haven't become a coke train yet
creepy eyes is [ __ ]
blasto rise [ __ ] and [ __ ] so we're
sitting there and one of my buddies goes
how good is that Coke from shotgunned
annulus why do you call Shotgun darkness
is the deal I think one day he's other
why he's at the crest wouldn't having
that the crest would have the Stonehenge
in Snowmass Village just like a little
resort bar you know live bands horrible
you just gonna get you dicks up and pick
up with rock with coke from the
bartender
coke was pure in those days up there
hope was claimed by all stepped on it
was coming in from the Steve rainbow
dude and the whole [ __ ] village had
tremendous coke it was a [ __ ] village
dog they had three bars so he picked up
this chick at the Stonehenge and he took
it back to the Crestwood where he took a
hotel room he was healing to the
employee housing but you had roommates
so he went took a key off the wall and
brought her up to a [ __ ] condo
wouldn't feel like a balcony in a veal
that drinkin there watching porn he's
jerking off on attendees the whole
[ __ ] package getting out of a ball on
the be snorting coke he snorted coke
he's throwing coffee stuff but doing
there was no no he kept leaving and
coming back to the hotel room when
twenty minutes later she would say what
are you bringing in and he didn't say
that he goes I'm bringing in some
clothes I guess spreads an idea we got
the condo for the night riding my gas
tease our skis and [ __ ] okay this goes
on a few times this one coke this long
come night in the morning they awakened
they don't even go to bed
the sun's coming out this Naughton blow
there's the first time I heard this hi
this is 1980
yeah this is 86 I heard this story
so Doug gets up in nine this long to
come to the chicks naked he's naked
he goes to a bathroom he comes back and
he goes where the second coke is missing
the chick says what are you talking
about he goes that was a bound to cook
when I went to the bathroom and then I
come back and there's two [ __ ] lines
where's the [ __ ] coke [ __ ] and get
up flap your tits up turn around
let me see your ass and she's like what
are you talking about doggy goes from
the three minutes - give me the [ __ ]
coke and she goes done I didn't take no
coke he runs until her Falcon back he
comes out with his shotgun
[ __ ] he was carrying a gun because he
would get paranoid he was that crazy
all right how many shots did he I have
no idea either careful moving on he ran
out he took the chick hostage she put a
gun to her Oh give me a [ __ ] give me
the [ __ ] coke he was like on the
second floor and some dealer balcony was
outside smoking a cigarette and saw this
so [ __ ] the cops came up there
surrounded the building he had the
shotgun and became a carro situation
they had a [ __ ] call somebody they
took him down took the shotgun away
hence this expression shotgun Doug ok
bomb now it's 1990 [ __ ] 493 how
quickly do you get out of prison fried
listen I don't ask question well I get
there was like shotgun daggers God he's
doing time ok he put a bullet some
chicks head on my shotgun Doug really
they go you got really bad on the blow
now it's 1993 mmm having Longmont
Colorado you know what the chances are
Bubba this on me alone Lynne Colorado at
that time there was one thing in
Longmont Colorado belly she'll fill
tacos they had the best breakfast taco
I've ever sink my teeth into for 69
cents hour and buy 15 of them and eat
him on the drive back the mold he
understand me I'm a professional yeah I
was lifting weights women I would live I
would walk into hurts and go Tommy you
got caught a little long money yes we do
see you in two hours peeled I would shoe
right to Delhi show so anyway Here I am
Christmas 1993 the party my new job mmm
I'm the kiss of death at the time
everything I'm touching turns to [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] how about this party at who do
I see playing basketball at the party
but shotgun done so while we're playing
basketball he yells over me though I
yelled at him shotgun Doug and he looks
up at me like all spooked and he goes
hey man how you doing then when he comes
up to me huh he slams me in the chest
well I think those who the [ __ ] you
think you are don't you ever call me
Sean
[ __ ] I'll go to my car suit you well we
kept playing basketball now I'm in the
game against him and while we're playing
you know me dog yeah I start with the
shotgun ducks shotgun Doug shotgun Doug
shaggin shaggin Doug he's getting redder
in the face by the [ __ ] with you 101
yes please our loved one
he's getting rather in the face by the
minute yeah there's a one nobody know
he's shotgun Doug Wow
he's putting his business out there yeah
he did something we know I'm company
thing so like she busted his balls
throughout this basketball game call him
shotgun
Doug shotgun gun he's frustrated me oh
yes I felt like someone who you want to
mess with to be honest yeah I don't
think I was shocked it was a [ __ ]
puke
and he became a worst puke and now he
was like a coke fiend mixed to it like
he was skinnier and he was really creepy
and he was a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
so he starts yelling back and forth you
know but you were in prison - you [ __ ] I
heard the whole story
you kidnapped some Czech and everybody's
looking at me now so that all [ __ ] I
put myself with this predicament
yeah they don't say nothing nobody said
so I wait a little while hermès jingle
Belling it wasn't true there was a
trailer the people drinking eggnog
it was cold cuts it was a nice sound
yeah they had to be [ __ ] 25 people
there everybody's having a good time
yeah I'm around the back of Hulu I see
shotgun duck and I [ __ ] you know he's
smoking a saying or that's what my
creeping skills we're on point like I
was good I thought not
oh yeah I was getting good before I went
to prison then I came out my creeping
skills wrong boy and it was something I
enjoyed doing sneaking up on somebody
you live to do that [ __ ] you do when
you're a kid that's funny to do in a
real life I got him and I got him by the
neck but they were doing that cuz slam
him up against where's the trailer where
the people having the Christmas
hmm so ice Leadville up against the
trail I tell you the story I clocked him
a few times next thing you know
everybody runs and goes what happened
he's like deers attacked me hang on you
tell them what you did you had a knife
you were gonna [ __ ] do all this [ __ ]
to me I didn't do nothin he's probably
shotgun even though shotgun doug is and
the rest is history they gave me my
check and fired me
Wow shotgun Doug shotgun dark man
resolution you know what you did
shotgunned oh no man I got Doug punk-ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] as my [ __ ] [ __ ] whoa
what time do you want tomorrow Hayes's
trail I am on at 12:30
that's a Late Late Show with James
Corden how old you know 31 you're very
interesting young man you have great
insight man you gonna do well to tell me
that's why you've done Wow
so well already you have dates of the
books anything uh November 11th
nohe November 12 I'll be an Ontario
improv improv doing a one-nighter
yeah you make good snot headline I want
to call the headline now I'm just I'm
just doing a show I adore this show yeah
yeah I started at the brain probably
once a month second Wednesday of the
month melee started working yeah I was
doing one Wednesday every month of the
brain probably I have 40 people and you
get 60 people then you got a hundred
people think another hundred people
another month then you go to 160 you
know like Jesus Christ I'm down strides
here on Wednesday nights because people
get used to you bring two comics planner
and now you start selling tickets and
it's not a bad little living once a
month but you don't want to kill
yourself
once the more you do it the less you're
gonna make right once every Wednesday
the second Wednesday of every month if
they know you're gonna be there no
[ __ ] show up don't pay the small
fifteen just to have two drinks leave
macaroni whatever those thick and those
mozzarella sticks yeah it's pretty
interesting when you really get to see
the other side of people like I'm gonna
do a documentary about fans of kind
faces of cadre the people who go to town
and you see the same couple that comes
in and that kind of thing I love what a
person comes up to me as a convict
enjoys his trail it's great to see you
know I've been a fan for a long time I
like that but I also might know people
who want to make our dog I can't be
nasty Bert Kreischer and big Jay
oakerson and lose gold bands they've
already Shaffir that gives me a
different admiration for a person
there's no show up with like a Bert
shirt and they don't be the sign or
something because you let me know you're
a fan of the cold water
yeah the heart yeah yeah absolutely
aren't the culture that that's what
makes my dick hard when people come up
there yeah let's take a picture I think
that's great but I like when people come
up and come up there with different
angles it's very realistic it's really
interesting I love when people come up
to me and it's got it looks like Lee
well that's a very decent hard-working
American and don't come up to you give
me a hug and go that was a good show you
know my favorite comic is going and
you're like okay yeah that's what you he
go really sinks so your favorite comic
is Galaga you [ __ ] don't look like
I was gonna cut watermelon still in your
[ __ ] yeah it's always nice to go into a
town or I'm always surprised when I see
people like yeah I came to three shows
this weekend to see like the same act or
whatever I'm like wow it's like that's a
special kind of person that's really
entertained by that bro where was I just
Tampa in Tampa a beautiful couple name
five shows in a row Wow Robert Anna they
came it came from Gainesville and
Jacksonville and they got that because
she pulled she went for the storm what's
up
and what to change she got a lottery
ticket i know ii got a 500 bucks so they
booked the hotel they got the tickets
all right how cool is that they came to
every show and they sent the same chair
and they were very sweet very that's so
cool and I promise if I come to
Jacksonville to see him because that's
how cool they were that's so cool what I
had to do better every night because
they were there or switch up a new joke
and it made me better I hate when people
come up to me like this week she came
out three so I came all five show like
god damn it but guess what every show I
look better and they saw that I could
tell they saw that every showing it
better
Thursday's just a warm-up but it's fun
because you find that gem in there huh
huh you find the gem when you're in
there silent and weave and find it yet
you bob and weave you mix the bobbin
weave yeah with the solid stuff you
blended just perfectly and you have a
tremendous know if there's anything and
now you know your boundaries you know
what I [ __ ] got killed with I got
killed this week the last show Saturday
late first show the sellout true church
trans I said something about somebody
we're standing outside the notify the
twin thousand umbrella
what 9/11 hit the building and [ __ ] and
having get one peep in there it just got
silent been there I had a [ __ ] pull a
grenade out of my ass three jokes later
the [ __ ] get him out of that [ __ ]
state of mind I [ __ ] myself sometimes
you know but that's what comedy is
that's what comedy is probably proving
that right there - oh yeah yeah you grow
it's weird that his channel I wish I was
going through this when I was 35 this
was the time to give me Road angles 154
you know I'm not on testosterone
I'm a natural [ __ ] proteins [ __ ] my
dad
so those four nights kill me
I could do three nights away from mom
and the kids and the sleep pattern you
know you gotta get up a train 3:00 in
the morning
I don't fly out I fly
early you know very sub like cats that
will fly the sunlight that I fly Papa
goes out the first flight yeah I'd
rather get there at 2:00 taking there
get some [ __ ] food from the ball they
come pick you up at 7:45 tip-top Magoo
you got to the club you smoked a number
you do your [ __ ] 50 minutes you take
a few pictures and you go back to the
hotel room if you have the radio and the
radio 100 if it's not a fan you stop at
the lens it's got a couple bags of
Doritos maybe a slim jim like a
[ __ ] maybe some Kit Kats this
[ __ ] look down on the water you go back
upstairs to your room
oh [ __ ] hey TNT got a loan on a marathon
with Anthony Anderson and Lupo and now
you living like a doc that's 2:00 in the
morning you're in [ __ ] Tampa Florida
with your feet up right you don't have
to get up in the morning well you give a
[ __ ] you're gonna watch all five episode
I whole goddamn marathon it's not it's
2:00 in the morning he there yeah but
it's 11 o'clock in LA so you're at the
Comedy Store 11 o'clock yeah I get into
your house till 1:00 dirty that means
you're not even faintly going to bed
till 4:30 4:30 5:00 yeah that's what
happens yeah and you feel bad because
people always saying you want to what
story yeah looking with the angle is it
I love you to death and I love you often
begins what I already looked at the TV
guy that the [ __ ] they got [ __ ]
John wick to one tonight and [ __ ]
11:40 I'm not happier they don't end
till 1:30 I've had hope I've been
waiting all day for John wick to you
know the saying right
I got to wait long [ __ ] day the calls
are coming in the caller from the
Ralphie May memorial oh oh that's right
it's very man I feel very bad but I
write the song man about guests they did
not wanna there's some people this is a
Hollywood Memorial which means when we
were Sally was about it's about actors
now who was going to show up there and
of the people that were going to show up
there tonight and the reasons they were
showing up there and I'm gonna do the
benefit in Nashville for Ralphie man his
birthday February 17th I think it is for
the kids scholarship fund but listen a
little Spanish people at the last four
out of five wakes of fuels I went
there's been a fist fight or an argument
the last it goes down like that yeah so
I have bad luck I think if I were the
guard there tonight I would have been in
a bad mood and I didn't want to
disrespect Ralphie or anybody so I chose
just to stay out of that mind my
business yeah behave like a gentleman
that's the best I could do no I came to
tribute tonight The Late Show and
[Music]
Lexington Kentucky I told the [ __ ]
whatever story I told the story will
taint the chicks [ __ ] and he saved me
and told a few stories about Ralphie is
his [ __ ] water
I was by the water for Ralphie obviously
made the smart adult decision but just
for the sake of a laugh don't you think
Ralphie would love it a little bit if
you went off on somebody I mean
depending who is I think Ralphie would
also rather be a circle
Ralphie was loved it and half the people
in that room would choose for me to go
off his the problem
I'm 54 years old I have a family I have
a nice little thing going on
what would I benefit from doing this or
further half the industry but what will
happen is if I went down there they have
anxiety attack you know ten years ago
well this month is when I stopped doing
blow like the 15th hectic Marilyn
Martinez died on the 6th
oh no no she died on the Rick Ramos his
birthday November 3rd or 4th something
around there oh I had to go to New York
for a benefit I didn't do blow that
weekend and I came back then I really
have a chance to do blow she was dead
then we have a church st. and actually I
get to the church who do I see but this
dude who's tortured Marilyn for last
three years he's there front and center
and this other comic that's well-known
made a statement that he knew Marilyn's
family and had money from the funeral so
he was gonna pay for the funeral well
the beauty of it was that the guy demand
that if he paid for the funeral he
wanted a certain person not to be there
this person that he demanded enough to
be there had been good to Marilyn this
kind is celebrity because of his ego
this was all gone and torn up only in a
Hollywood wake I would see this when I
grew up this would be a grounds for
[ __ ] a beat up uh-huh a throwdown so
this was all going on at the church
already this all went down at the church
I left I had to go to some exercise
class or something and I'll say good
whatever the [ __ ] that is up to hell
that Los Feliz and that night they were
doing a benefactor Comedy Store I was
getting sponsored by a restaurant
I hadn't done coke in a few days brother
so I was on that you already say how is
there any killing [ __ ] over here
and I'm not sure if I stopped and got
coke or well that was my plan to cut
this [ __ ] I was a junkie and against my
will a dear friend called me at the time
I said listen how it'll look if you do
it's gonna be [ __ ] up I can't go down
and I just had a feeling I know me right
you know it hasn't hit me yet the Ralphy
thing I didn't want to hit me down there
no you know what Madeleine didn't hit me
till I got there that had the picture of
her I thought about the main room I'm
sitting I walked in with my suit on I
look over and that dude that was playing
games you know he's eating the food oh
yeah
the free food that they give this guy's
a [ __ ] produc'd made a ton of money
off all the Latino telly [ __ ] smoke
was coming out of mine he's been smoked
I had to turn away and go in the bar and
have a drink which I never drink at that
[ __ ] ball but between the no blow and
this guy was at it was it came to a boil
and I'm sitting there minding my own
business woman chick says listen you got
to go up there first and hold up the
show so was my Cuban escorial do a peg
go up there at the three minutes I stuck
calling awful thing I have a Mabel I
tell them I like it on stage I'm gonna
[ __ ] him up and blah blah blah and they
got a squat me out of the store and it
was very embarrassing I knew what the
whole rage was about he deserved it
don't get me wrong I'm not apologizing
at all and then the word got out that I
was a [ __ ] gorilla some people start
talking to me some people stop booking
me for certain thing in fact I heard
repercussions from it two years ago and
it broke my [ __ ] heart
nothing likely said I think you did the
grown-up thing this this time with
Ralphie
I know me we've had we we've had some
brilliant times in here Ralphie have you
[ __ ] think of this podcast and how
much fun we've had in here I think that
the spirit of Ralphie always living this
[ __ ] podcast wow this is crazy
it wasn't even Ralphie's podcast but
when he was on it it was his podcast if
you disagree lee-sia I had my kidney he
would start from the minute he walked in
that fine though I mean I went down to
get him at the car he would give me a
hug but then he would tell me he was
like you know Lee I was one of the first
members of the church to what's
happening now and then he would we would
just talk anyway he's the reverend but
what I even go he would go off for a
given Pilate look at this big Etha Benny
Lee start going off and then he would
sit in the chair you would hear the
chair [ __ ] breather for his life that
point that point chair you would have
every time he moves a little bit and I
don't like the springs will be going
Jesus Christ and then he would just come
on here and start talking nonsense he
hated Russians they hated a [ __ ] rest
my best friend he was just having fun
you guys have had fun and you know what
we'd sit there and go Jesus Christ look
at the podcast numbers look at the
podcast that was around he comes out it
was like a different dimension well I
couldn't believe it he was like the
first big guest that would come on and
really line up the numbers and I would
listen to a little bit of the podcast
and I would see why the podcast was
really like here's a great laugh you can
feel the love in the room yeah and
that's really really I dig yet I really
dig what you're doing a zoom that you
would be sitting here on the right
[ __ ] path I have to say means owe me
the world so nice and that's us as crazy
[ __ ] here under those words man 54 years
old I don't have much left but I'll tell
you what I do have left mono it's not
like my eyes are that 20/20 but for what
I need my eyes
because I'm always watching I'm watching
who's down there begging watch this was
down there working and I'm also hearing
about who's putting things together and
they're putting things together I have
to respect because that's what I had to
do I think gonna Montreal nobody [ __ ]
wanted to sign me as a manager it was a
nightmare
I was my first agency was the coloring
book this this that paperwork was pink
and orange I put all your headshots on
colored paper it was [ __ ] amazing and
every month you got to change the paper
so you'll end up at mr. Yang's printing
over there on Sunset across it like it's
hot 7 it's out of business now mr. Chow
is printing
mr. yang ciao uncle childless and you
know I'm very [ __ ] names no manse
it's out of [ __ ] business now what I
didn't have that type of help so
everything you got
you had a workflow like unit and that's
the main thing I know when I get a call
and I know who's [ __ ] no you know
saying I'm sure wow you learned the
tweak in the voice yeah in 2007 when I
made that my decision I told a couple
people to stop calling me it was a
painful decision as I said that's
necessary they stopped being my friends
but guess what else happened they never
came around again
they didn't do nothing his comics just
like I thought they were out for the
quick fix
they were hard to latch on to somebody
to take him on the road so they could
tell their friends pick up chicks smoke
pot and then one day they do some in the
hotel room the relationship will be over
and you never hear from that dude again
now in circles he'd be off welding at a
[ __ ] school or something like that
I'm not saying nothing bad about welders
I love you [ __ ] I'm just saying
that he disappeared in the end of the
world but I think you have a future here
see you at the store yeah you're
handling yourself onstage thanks fine
you have a good time on stage was very
at the store young comics like myself
always kind of nervous the spine well I
could tell that smile on your face that
you're very relaxed up there that's why
do I go down there the best thing about
the store is not performing well and
that's what people don't know that's the
hard part the best part of the store is
smoking a joint and sit in the back
don't down at age 45 and even though
your spots at 11:45 just sitting in the
back of the chair don't talk to nobody
you don't want to talk to nobody you
want to sit in the back and see how he
hypnotizes the audience to see if he
gets you know you play that game by
yourself when you see those bill burns
that's what you have to go in that tom
pappas
yeah and you know it's fun on our
[ __ ] clinic it's funny to me because
a lot of people expect to go see a
comedian and he's not a machine gun
timing and they don't want he's not as
funny as expected no you didn't read
this to his setups you didn't listen
through his punchlines correctly you
know you were listening for something
else that dudes are brilliant [ __ ]
comic now you came here to see some
[ __ ] Union machine that's up there
jumping up and down doing bad jokes but
the star tonight was a Thom popper those
guys yeah who were surges yeah they're
[ __ ] surgeons they dissect a room in
a different way then Bill burr would Joe
Rogan know
Sebastian Maniscalco Neal Brennan will
search your eyes a room you know are
they gonna get on their feet and fall
out of that chair
no but he's gonna mentally warfare you
yeah well you're gonna laugh because
your brains gonna rattle and that's what
so great about comedy is so subjective
yes I'm fair about it yeah do any stuff
use the other stories you see all these
styles I mean I remember when I first
got to the store me and he was but I was
his roommate I lived on one of his bunk
beds but I'll never forget watching Doug
Stanhope in the hospital room the best
on a Saturday night at 8:45 when the
original would be sold out and bang so
it would be like Argus Hamilton yeah and
then it would be like a lesbian comic
there was a Tron never forget this
certain thing where there was a short
little lesbian comic uh-huh and she went
up there at 8:30 you know cookies I'm a
lesbian comic coming to the stage Doug
stamina he walked out things like this
chick is a [ __ ] lesbian like I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] he goes you know the real
lesbian is I realize me there's a holy
cage right now coaches a bunch of little
girls with a [ __ ] [ __ ] ring or sigh
he just went off that original rule what
at this shot 8:30 show a half team show
on a satellite no earlier for her father
never forget sitting in the doorway and
watched it's Doug Stanhope break their
or everybody's back just went tough at
the same time he just started talking
about this lesbian she was in the back
oh Jesus Christ with what I do Doug
Stanhope machine-gunner update talking
about coming on your tits
he saw his mother's [ __ ] and was like a
spider so he stepped on it you know he
just went off and you're in the back as
a comic [ __ ] Howard yeah you know
just amazed at the talent I'll never
forget like I saw town New York but it
[ __ ] up rooms I'll never forget until
the first time I saw it telling the
original they gave a guest spot at like
9:15
and maybe maybe there was 45 people
that's when the whole back was at the
end the sides just the middle would be
scattered and I'll never forget him
going on a Thursday night talking about
his cocaine went down the plane I love
young complain that was Pablo Escobar be
he was [ __ ] riffing up there he still
had the sparkler was the gay cousin to
the Firecracker and all those things you
know who likes firecrackers raise your
hooks he destroyed that original room
that [ __ ] would make my dick hard when I
was up there in the beginning the better
then paul moody yeah to watch him come
in and then you had a follow that same
who would be sitting right there and
panic what am I gonna do oh my god you
go through 20 exciting fast I couldn't
leave the room right because he might
get offered he would not bring you up he
was a good night [ __ ] and he would
just put the mic in the thing and walk
off then the piano player would have to
run over there put a couple of those
stays Joey Diaz and as you're walking up
half the room is empty now it went from
46 people to 18 right before your eyes
you know what that does the ego we
that's a killer in all that's like me
kicking in the stomach after the show I
can't even imagine oh yeah see the chair
broke from Ralphie backyards we put the
cursor off yellow there's a little
credit chain went down look by out back
on the [ __ ] table three times listen
this sadly I'm gonna be at the
[ __ ] Ice House 7:30 working out
with uncle Joey and then next week
November 2nd or something like that I'm
at the Omaha funnybone then November
10th time I [ __ ] Gotham comedy club
how's that for you for the New York
Comedy Festival
suck my dick and call me shorty uncle
Joey was born in 1940 I want to thank my
man hey zoos trainer are starting to
rise where can they find you my brother
hey Suz Francom twitter at hey soos
Trejo and
on Instagram at hey sue strike on the
number one love you brother
love you man again this is bra [ __ ] no I
have to watch my brother tomorrow I give
him some digits tape and at least a
paddy B yard watch it later then [ __ ]
get rid of it if you don't want to watch
him give him some love he's [ __ ]
young guy this guy's gonna have his own
church in [ __ ] seven years this is
the guys you gotta watch out for me I'm
gonna old goat no stop it
I love you [ __ ] Lisa at my
favorite [ __ ] [ __ ] in all the
world I love you too my brother love you
too you guys Wednesday night 8 o'clock
we got a great podcast as usual we'll
stay black
don't forget Saturday Icehouse following
Thursday [ __ ] Omaha funnybone
[ __ ] love you stay black thank you
thank you